hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to lost in vivo a horror
game that's supposed to capitalize on
feelings of claustrophobia so if you are
claustrophobic buckle up cuz it's gonna
be a fun ride and also I'm not 100% sure
but I think it might meet by the same
company plus a butcher a pooper it is a
poopy boot shirt same company that did
Spooky's House of jump-scares I believe
it's lack studios I'm pretty sure about
also it warned me at the beginning of
the game there's a symbol that will
appear when something is after me oh
this is so claustrophobic oh I know
exactly what it's talking about oh just
the the field oh I'm getting flashbacks
from vanish oh I don't like that at all
okay here we go yeah the field of view
is just extremely skewed to make you
feel like everything is way closer than
it should be oh geez distances are all
wrong yeah okay well that one's all
blocked up so I guess I'll go down the
illuminated
here can I run oh I can I can skedaddle
a little bit I'm looking for my dog
mark barf barf barf oh god I didn't know
who's gonna be looking for my dog let's
have three eyes how about let's have two
and call it a day bark bark
oh no tika come back it's okay Oh chica
she's not in the room right now so
otherwise she'd be going crazy
Oh chica ruff
Oh buddy buddy Oh little buddy oh I'm
coming for you oh no little buddy is
this a dead end I can barely tell
without the field of view is Oh teeth oh
good yeah we're gonna have three teeth
three eyes three teeth three noses three
mouths
ooh watch it
Poochie Poochie chica chica chica
squeakers junker bunkers jungles get
over here
okay oh this doesn't look good I also
should mention that this is just a demo
the full game is trying to be
kick-started right now so I'll put a
link in the description
well those are good oh so good sorry
[Music]
Oh
I was scared by a radio it sounded like
it was getting closer because I was
running quiet I'm an idiot okay I know
that now I'm an idiot I'm a big dumb I
am a dumb I don't like this yeah I was
like I always know it's good horror game
when I got that sense of dread was that
straight ahead I think it was straight
ahead okay I think so yeah Oh No
moochers
you betrayed me moochers you betrayed me
[Music]
blue tears why don't you just come to me
dang it unless you're just as lost as I
am which is probably the case Oh
butchers I probably shouldn't be
whistling just in case something else is
out here
[Music]
ah don't like that
chica no I don't want to go down this
way don't go down this way
close that oh this is life liquor yeah
oh is that blood or rust me you're a
kitty cat oh no no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh oh is
that meat in the TV where's their meat
Oh someone who's watching the old telly
okay huh oh please don't kill me
oh good a hammer can I use that oh who
lives down here okay I got this ah for
self-defense
yeah no one wants the best of me can I
knocked it done yeah whoa check out the
wampa John that okay there's no more
chicas non-responding park though
[ __ ] hell
hi hello hi no come on here ah come on
oh hey is that Simon from cry of fear
you Beth do if my buffer you bird you
wear my pup I gave my eyes to the devil
hug a [ __ ] and his Simon [ __ ] you get
[ __ ] you [ __ ] get killed he deserved
it I exploded him in to meet with my
mind oh yeah you deserved it he deserved
it
[Music]
goober pop puppy pooper
that sounds really meaty okay oh this is
good oh that's not good
oh man turning in here so disorienting
what is back there what's back there is
it what's blue bobbin
oh it's what's glue but isn't it I'll
fight ya I'll fight ya Ruby oh [ __ ] whoa
something's wrong with that wall
something's wrong with this wall
something tells me this wall is gonna
disappear and I'm gonna be chased oh no
someone over there - I think so oh yeah
someone's over there
oh good oh good it's a cavalcade of
Horrors I wonder what would happen if I
didn't kill it
bloppy goobers chica no that is gendered
hi okay I just continue forward then
what doesn't seem to be any reason for
me to look
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye oh I
don't like that all hope abandon ye who
enter in oh good
Magda pile of meat so there was nothing
over there
there was nothing over there before I
enter this sewer no bouquet there's
nothing okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
now going forward
Oh visions visions bothered me so it
took them out but they still worked I
could still see so I ate them to make it
stop but they're still working please
help me Oh God
Curtis Rick's Charen oh I just slipped
right in yeah I thought it was gonna be
a like a level transition or something
[Music]
I can't whistle anymore oh what is that
oh what is that oh what is that oh what
is that I don't want to know what that
is okay I might find out what that is
but I don't want to know what that is
yeah okay goodbye
okay
okay okay oh geez god it's so easy oh oh
geez okay
all right then ah good oh oh well that's
not nice
well that's not nice oh I'm starting to
feel ill ah is that my blood or did I
just splash in blood because my blood
pitchers that's unser that'd be
something ever me let me study after me
that's what it said it said that this
something was after me it said that
something was after me didn't it
this was a sensible getting the game
maybe you guys didn't see it cuz it was
before I started recording that's why
you guys didn't are you what are you
gonna sewer is this Oh what are you lose
anything else here that easy
Oh hard to look around hmm I don't like
this war my god
what is it squealing behind me should I
look probably not
hey big guy okay right then you have fun
there yeah I definitely think this is
made by the same guy that made Spooky's
House of jump-scares or same people good
it deserved to die probably probably
probably just theorizing put it out of
its misery and why not Luger's mark mark
mark mark mark mark mark mark mark what
Wow come on they're poachers aw man I
would have gone down the other pathway
there's probably something
oh that was good that was good though oh
man that kept me on the edge of my seat
that was really good
dog question mark Oh what are you trying
to say there dog handler dog question
mark why are you even here good question
none of this matters oh geez booty's
nothing matters who bubar was anything
real no life isn't real
you're not real
I don't have nightmares anymore
I can't see them anymore
[Music]
I don't know did they die
did I die I don't know the end happened
a long time ago oh oh man yeah that was
cool that was really cool and that was
just a Kickstarter demo that could be
its own little small horror game by
itself that's really cool that was
really cool I got I have a lot of good
things to say about this but again this
is just a demo I mean something is after
you sometimes it doesn't though pay it
no mind it lies oh I'm the only one you
can trust
ah I didn't read all of that oh that was
cool and there's no options there's no
option so thank you everybody so much
for watching I want a full game like
this this was really good it was so like
disorienting with the field of view in
the way that it was but I think that
worked very well to create a sense of
unease it was really really well done
and I like that a lot so I'm going to
support this Kickstarter oh there's a
bug in and if you guys feel like it's
worthy you can play the demo for
yourself maybe there was some secret
Easter eggs that I didn't find because I
was too scared to go down certain paths
so thanks again and as always
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]